Jaakko I have a question for you I know
you're a very busy guy how do you find
time to read so many books I have I have
many that I want to read but I've
trouble having enough time any advice on
how to set aside time to do so sure you
know make time
what do you what what are you doing all
day
the clocks tickin what are you doing all
that are you watching TV are you surfing
the internet
are you watching YouTube videos that's
my question
what are you doing before you go to
sleep at night are you looking at
Twitter are you looking at Instagram
posts the Instagram videos tell me
they're not like an addiction you get
the you get the the Instagram video
every one of them is funny they're 38
seconds long then 1 minute long get to
see people hurt themselves get to see
people do dumb things and make you feel
good about yourself mm-hmm I didn't do
that dumb thing someone else did I can
laugh at them how long you gonna look at
those videos for when you could be
reading so so there you go stop wasting
a bunch of time and then what about
audiobooks what do you get what are you
doing when you're mowing the lawn what
are you doing when you're trimming the
hedges what are you doing when you're
pulling weeds what are you doing when
you're cleaning the dishes get some
audiobooks get some audiobooks
what are you doing first thing in the
morning what are you doing are you
waking up checking your email sitting
around waiting you know wasting a bunch
of time are you getting up early enough
that you could just get up get out of
bed go and read for 30 minutes 30
minutes that's what you have to do you
have to make time there's plenty of time
to read there's plenty of time to read
you probably don't want to read as badly
as you're as you think
if you wanted to read that bad you'd
make time you make time to breathe
somehow yeah well I can make time to
breathe you can make time to read yeah I
don't say yes yeah II would be a better
one cuz like ya eat I think because read
you can read while you're doing other
things sometimes especially with you
just just kind of like as a as a so I'm
reading I'm always have to be reading a
book to read a book for the podcast
right yeah I had only read the first
maybe ten books that we read you know
that we did on the podcast we've done a
hundred or something now probably more
than that I had only read like ten of
them maybe it may be a few more but I'd
read them so long ago maybe I'd read
thirty but I'd read some so long ago
that just I had to reread them and so
then you say to yourself okay so winning
would you know when I read all the time
I read go to bed good reading wake up
reading mm-hm
going in an airplane will see people
what do people do in an airplane you
watch a movie I know you sleep they do
all the stuff I sleep sometimes as an
airplane but will from not sleeping get
us I guess what I'm doing
reading proper for broadcasting I can
attest it oh yeah what do you think is
the like the biggest ones that people
are you know that you know the biggest
activities times naked yeah that they
could just stop and you just for me I
think the biggest time sucks are YouTube
I think Instagram I think those two are
really what's the word stimulating to
the brain yeah and you actually get this
weird like well I actually like I'm
gonna learn a little something from this
right here I'm gonna take something away
from this I'm gonna veg out I'm going to
escape from my world right now
it's like escapism right yeah and and
they they actually have algorithms that
are that know what you will click on
they actually know that about you they
mapped your little brain
and know that if they put up a video
that has if they put up a thumbnail of a
video and it's got a heavy machine gun
in it they they know they got a good
chance I'm gonna click on it right and
then they give it a catchphrase title
right you know they give it a
catchphrase title Isis gets master click
Oh 50 Cal versus Taliban oh cool right
yeah oh yeah yeah and after they know
ours you're gonna click on ma'am and
that's that's so and what do you get out
of it you watch it for 20 minutes or
game yeah you get nothing out of it you
get a book you read you learn you write
something that's what you do yeah that
and actually the YouTube thing is it's
very if that's one of your things it's
worse than its it's not just YouTube
who's trying to get you to watch the
video it's the video makers themselves
so YouTube has an algorithm oh they got
it all kind of sorted out there and now
the video makers they make titles like
50 Cal versus XYZ and awful punches too
and guess what 50 Cal versus you can
fill in the blank you're probably gonna
watch that video motivation speech ever
yes yeah oh yeah so so in so destroys
whatever destroys reporter in interview
yeah exactly right so once is really
owned actual basically right when you
log on to YouTube
once YouTube pops up on your screen bro
everyone on that screen is all sucking
your attention literally that's their
job sucking your attention so yeah man
that's a big one right Instagram so
here's the here's here's one that it
really hit me really hard a gram the
gram oh and I like you Instagram it's
like good but if you're like trying to
read you know if you want to read more
or whatever consider like even like
let's say we start recording this for a
second we're look at the bus on our
phones we're gonna maybe checking email
maybe we got a text or whatever and the
probability of Instagram coming up on
there we're gonna you know open it but
the probability of us opening Instagram
is is pretty significant it's pretty
high and you can scroll through there
whatever even if you scroll for two
three minutes right you scroll through
there maybe what you looked at 15 20
people's post read what they had to say
well if you have a Kindle or something
right you do that same thing it's like
kind of like a fuse and you could read
yeah read instead so if you had a camera
like once you said like imagine your
video being videotaped like what if
you're being videotaped all day and all
I did was calculate every time you
opened up Instagram or Facebook or
Twitter and or YouTube all those patear
every time we open up at instant and you
had that scenario in one a ver egde day
when you take all that time and replace
it with you open your Kindle to read
more bust out a book you know you bring
books or whatever with you and that's
how to instead of doing that you did the
book right you know much reading you do
right you'd read so much a lot of
reading yeah so it's like yeah those are
the time sucks man your phone it's so
available you know yeah what bright you
can read on your phone - mm-hmm that's a
big one TV - you watch TV not really but
I watch one show now and actually -
Hawaii five-o and that's it sometimes
Shark Tank that's it 100% it's weird
what is how often is the Hawaii five-o
on once a week and it goes in season so
you got how long is this season
I don't know thirteen episodes I guess I
don't know I have no know but unless I
have watched one TV show recently it's
called billions there's a little
scenario unfolding on the log billions
all right well actually yeah and keep in
mind it's not like I've never seen any
other show ever and never will it's not
that thing you know people they like not
watched I know routine yeah and actually
I will separate the fact that nowadays
you can watch TV in a different way
right it's not like at 8 o'clock on a
Thursday night you got to sit there and
watching it - yeah 30 minute show with
the 30 minutes worth of commercials in
it yeah right no you can you're you're
on a flight somewhere you've read you
got to take it easy on your eyes a
little bit if you start reading too much
you've read
a long time okay you're gonna stare out
the window for a little while listen to
this part of a podcast or something then
you're like okay my brain is like barely
functioning yeah okay I'm gonna watch an
episode of billions yeah
ballers you everything ballers I don't
know the difference well I do know the
difference I watch that for a little bit
but me you know like people have a
routine like tonight you know every
night for 30 minutes they watch TV with
their kids or whatever it's like that
doesn't really happen anymore yeah next
question sad how much time you can waste
these days with the distractions and
people trying to get that time from you
yeah your discipline like when you when
you first start saying disciplining clio
when I first started hearing it from you
that was like one of the things that
popped into my head like as being really
obvious like if you are disciplined with
your time you'll have a lot of free time
like a lot a lot of free time way more
than you would think anyway cuz you know
even when I'm like real busy you know if
I can accurately remember my dick
remember like just like five minutes
here fifteen minutes there like that I
did something that was a waste of time
and if you add up all those little
minutes you have probably hours probably
hours for to do yeah do something for
group progressive you know productive
work negative progressive progress your
life valuable valuable all those things
check